when you just guest hosted on Saturday
Night Live yeah [ __ ] killed it right
you elevated that show I said this on
the excellent yeah thank you a couple of
things stuck out you did this song about
Chris Farley yes which brought the place
down brought a tear to everyone's eye
was it was it was poignant in the way
that like it's like a Bruce Springsteen
song is like a mage's Faris the guy made
you think right right right
you did the monologue and you sang to
about getting fired yeah oh yeah talk to
me about that yes don't you think
psychologically cuz I was watching this
thing thinking Sandler finally had his
day because Lauren fired you in some
mysterious [ __ ] way and suddenly you
come back to guest host after saying no
for all those years
you kill it and you're probably in the
back of mind saying still [ __ ] you I
like it this Rob the mic there I gotta
be honest I didn't have any I think I
might have been like that 15 years ago
right if I came on and did well and like
yeah I'm I'm [ __ ] old enough now I
realize what Saturday Night Live did for
me and put the fire let's turn that down
played at the time I was hurt because I
was I didn't know what else I was gonna
do and I know it wasn't
Lorne decision the NBC head dude I know
he didn't like our gang I mean Farley
and they had a winning cast there and
you had been there for five years you
probably have stayed one or two at least
maybe more maybe I would have never left
because well I'm not good at saying
goodbye but seriously I had to get rid
of me Sam when they fired you it really
caught you by surprise put a lump in my
throat only again everyone turned out
great we don't write the ending of the
story but at the time you were livid I
was probably sad into covering the
sadness up with being mad and saying
yeah [ __ ] you above but I remember when
I saw Farley and he said me too they
don't want me we were both like [ __ ]
this
we got mad together pretended pretended
we weren't sad and pretended this was
for the best but but move fire I want to
know this
what fired this is how I got fired I my
manager
sandy he was talking to me and I said
yeah next year on the show bubble bond
he was like maybe you know go back next
year and I was like I don't know man
I still got a few more things he's like
yeah think about it I think you thought
about it thinking you need